like do you watch Tik Tok a lot or I try
not to touch Tik Tok IES sad I pay a guy
to do it and I don't look I don't look
at it yeah they call digital fentanyl
it's the new term yeah it just sucks you
in you lose eight hours yeah my lady's
on it all day and I'm like I never get
to talk to her and the comments and the
the videos will get to me and they'll
change my perspective on things but then
I wonder who are the people making these
it's always the saddest people like like
like with relationship stuff they'll be
like never trust anyone like I got
burned this way this way and it's it's
never a positive thing it's always just
like a bummer thing and I'm like is this
the world that is the world and then you
think how many hours and hours people
are just putting into these videos
setting up cameras girls dancing and
you're like man if Tik Tok didn't exist
you would have figured something else
out you would be exercising or playing
piano or reading or something or just
jacking off or jacking off that's fun
too that's good and that's healthy